blue prism is a global leader in
intelligent enterprise automation
transforming the way employees work by
making it simple
for individuals to automate operations
blueprism helps enterprises
improve operational efficiency and
agility
hey everyone i welcome you all to this
session
in this session we will see a tutorial
on blue prism
let's look at today's agenda firstly we
shall begin with
the introduction to blue prism and then
see the user interface of blue prism
followed by which we will understand the
core components of blue prism
like process studio object studio
application modeler
and others finally we will have a
hands-on session
watch the video till the end to not miss
the hands-on session
if you haven't watched our previous
video on what is blue prism
i would suggest you to go through it for
better understanding
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with tutorial on
blueprism
introduction to blueprism
blueprism is software that develops
enterprise robotic process automation
allowing businesses to automate complex
end-to-end operations
blueprism developed the virtual
workforce platform concept
and works on an enterprise robotic
process automation platform
that is strong highly scalable secure
and reliable
blueprism software complements standard
it solutions
by utilizing an agile virtual workforce
that follows
rule-based business processes and
interacts with the system
in the same way that users do
blueprism's rpa software solution
automates tasks that would otherwise be
carried out manually by humans
or through major customization of
current i.t systems
resulting in higher level of automation
with significantly lesser
investment and faster deployment
blue prism user interface there are six
types of taps in blue prism
that is home studio control analytics
releases and system
the home page includes many charts that
provide information on the blueprism
database
the workforce availability metric
displays the runtime resources
that we are utilizing the amount of
queues
and automation in the database is shown
by total automation
queue volumes now displays queue volumes
based on the statuses
and largest database table displays the
blueprism database
largest tables
studio blueprism studio is a critical
component
through which we build actual automation
actions with studio
we can automate a process build a
process using flow
add logic calculations and intelligence
without writing any code
drag in actions calculations loops and
more
in studio we can connect the blocks in
preferred order
use smart skills from digital exchange
digital exchange is where we can find
ready-made skills to enhance
the automation with machine learning ai
language translation
and many more the studios are divided
into two categories
object studio and process studio control
room
control room assigns the process to
digital workers
user can quickly start a process by
dragging it on to a resource
the control room is the key
administrative point in blue prism
where we can handle the control
monitoring execution
and scheduling of process executions on
dispersed robots
analytics blueprism analytics is a
module
that allows you to see data graphically
in the form of charts
such as pi column gauge and line
releases the release manager is used to
manage configuration package
import and export between multiple blue
prism settings
system administrators use the system tab
to manage users
let's look at some of the blue prism
components
some of the blue prism components are
process studio
object studio application modular
exception handling
and work use
a blue prism process is created as a
diagram that looks much like a common
business flow diagram
we can call from the process studio if
the page is published
for development and testing we use
process studio
process studio has only main page
object studio
object studio is mostly used to create
objects
we have several type of activities
within the object
which are as follows that is the modular
application
to spy the elements initialize page and
cleanup page
the next component is application
modular
the application modeler is used to spy
on apps spying is a process of
identifying the elements in the
applications
we have four different types of spying
modes that is
win32 mode html mode
accessibility mode and region mode
the next component is exception handling
the managing of exceptions in unattended
automation
is defined as exception handling it
ensures that faults can be automatically
fixed if possible
or that they are easily identified and
repairable by system administrators
or they can be forwarded for human
completion if necessary
exception handling success is determined
by how well it is implemented throughout
the development
exception handling is a critical part of
any blue prism solution
an exception is a problem that arises
during the execution of a process
when errors are encountered in blue
prism it generates exceptions
exception handling stages
exception handling can be achieved using
resume
recover and exception stage
in the resume stage it ends a block for
handling exceptions
in recovery it begins a block for
handling exceptions
in exception stage explicit rises an
exception in the execution of process
or an object the different types of
exception
are internal exception system exception
and business exceptions internal
exceptions come based on our missing
mandatory data in stages
system exceptions will occur based on
internet is down
or our robot need internet or any system
failures
business exceptions these exceptions are
not actually exceptions
however based on the business rules we
are creating the exceptions
we need to fire manually through bot
work queues
our queue is a list that may be
configured internally to help a process
manage its workload
a process may use numerous work use and
a work you may be shared by multiple
processes
if necessary the control room queue
management tab
serves as the operational user interface
for work use
the tab is divided into two sections
the upper half displays a list of queues
while the lower half displays a list of
queue items
in the configuration of work u work use
are formed in the blue prism's
administrative
area system manager now let us look at a
demo on email
automation if you haven't installed a
blue prism software yet
then check out our video on blue prism
installation and get it installed
so let's jump into blue prism software
and get started with the email
automation
let's first sign in blue prism
click on next this is the overview about
the home page
studio and control room and digital
exchange
close it let's go to studio
the very first step is to import email
pop3
smtp business object to import that go
to file
go to import process object
and go to browse you have to go to the
folder where blue prism software is
installed
in my device it's installed in c
go to local disk c go to program files
and go to blue prism limited
blue prism automate here scroll down
and go to vbo business objects
and here you can see email pop3
smtp select click on open select this
and click on open and click on
next
click on next
click on next
so when you're done with this the email
pop3 smtp
will be imported the next thing is
create a new process so select process
go to create new process and let's name
the process
we'll name the process as
email automation
click on next enter a description
of this process if you want so that if
some other user opens the file
he should know that what is the process
about so enter the description
it's optional so we'll click on finish
and let's open this process now
the very first step is to drag and drop
and action so select action and drop it
here
open this action
so in first step we will set up the
email of pop3 smtp
business object so we'll name it as name
this action as setup
select the business object as email pop3
smtp
and the action is configure we are
configuring it
and here we have to enter the username
password of the server
details so from where do we get the
server details
to get the server details we have to go
to the browser
go to the browser and
search as gmail server configuration
here you see you will get the all the
details here
the port number the email
so in the smtp server we'll enter the
smtp.gmail.com and the port number as
587
and in the pop3 we will enter pop
gmail.com and port number as 995.
and both the servers will turn it on
to turn it on we'll write it as true
so we'll go back to the blue prism
so enter the server
pop.gmail.com enter it in the double
quotes
an smtp server enter as smtp
not gmail.com
and the pop report number is 995
and the smtp port number is 587
and pop use ssl should turn it on to
turn it on we need to enter the value as
true
okay now we should enter the username
and password
if i enter the password here for example
if i enter the password here the
password is visible
we don't want the password to be visible
the password should be encrypted
so for the password to be encrypted in
data item there is an option called
passwording data types
so go to data item
drag and drop a data item
and select the data type as password
and enter the password here here the
password will be
encrypted
and click on ok
we'll name the data item as password
similarly we will use another data item
for username
name the data item as name select the
data type as
text and give the initial value
so enter your email id
and click on ok so now we have username
and password
now go to the setup and select the
username and password
drag and drop this username
and in the passwords drag and drop the
password
so so the setup is done
the next step is
the next step is we want to enter the
subject and the data in the mail
right for that we need to use another
action
item drag and drop another action
name it as sending message
select the business object as email pop
sm
tp
and go to action and in the action
select the action as send message
here you need to enter the email id to
whom you want to send so i'll enter the
email id which we had entered in the
username
enter both the from and to email ids so
i'll use the same email id
since this is just for demo i'm using
the same email id
so enter the subject subject i'll enter
it as
demo and enter the body
hello
so now that we have entered the subject
and body let's
close this and now let us
now use the link and connect it
now let us click on run and check
whether we have received the
email
oops there is an error we have missed
something
oh we have missed a double quoted
let us save again
reset and run
so the process is completed let us go to
the email
inbox and check whether we have received
the email
so let me refresh and here you go
we have received the email
as hello and the subject is done so we
have received the email
now let us send it with an attachment so
for that
we go to the blue prism
we go to sending message here here you
can see attachment
attachment is of the data type
collection
right so for that we need to use a
collection
item so drag and drop a collection
go to collections and
click on import select the business
object
as email and select the action
as send message and the parameter
with attachments select the attachment
and click on ok next go to initial value
in initial value click on add you can
add multiple
path here and attach how many other
attachments you want
for now we'll attach only one attachment
so you need to provide the
file path here so we'll go to the
desktop
so i have this article on desktop so
i'll attach this article in the email
so select this article
shift and right click and copy as path
copy this path go back to blue prism
and provide the path here
remove the double quotes
and click on ok
so once the collection item is completed
go back to sending message
go to collections here in the collection
select this
and click on ok
click on reset and let us run
and here you go you can see the process
is completed
so let us go to the email inbox and
check if we have received an email with
an attachment
so here we go we have received the email
with the attachment
let us open it the same email with the
subject demo
and the body as hello and with the
article which i had attached
rpa projects so i have received the
attachment so with that we have reached
the end of this video that was all about
the demo on email automation
if you have any doubts regarding this
video you can comment in the comment
section
and our team will try to answer and like
and share it if you found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here